[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro du 7-8 sport le
tour d'horizon de l'actualité sportive
du département tout de suite le sommaire
du handball avec la victoire des
féminines de montigny le bretonneux
opposé au paris saint-germain pour le
premier match de la saison de nationale
2 elles l'ont emporté sur le score de 32
à 28
retour sur cette rencontre rugby dans
quelques jours l'ouverture de la coupe
du monde c'est au japon quel parcours
pour le quinze de france quelles
retombées pour les club yvelinois
nous recevons notre consultant pierre
chevalier du rugby-club de versailles
avec lui nous parlerons aussi du début
de saison de son club en fédérale 3 et
de léobard est un jeune versailles est
sélectionné en équipe de france moins de
18 ans enfin du basket ball avec la
première à domicile pour les joueuses du
chesnay versailles pour leur retour en
nationale 2 et reçoivent dunkerque au
gymnase du bel air c'est samedi 21
septembre à 14 heures nous avons suivi
leurs préparations met tout de suite les
résultats sportifs du week-end
[Musique]
et on commence avec le 3e tour de la
coupe de france et les résultats des 17
club yvelinois en lice pour cette phase
à noter notamment la performance du
petit poucet maisons laffitte deux des
quatre vainqueurs 3 0 face à hugo à
garches vaucresson et la victoire lors
des prolongations de vale 78 1 à 0
contre courbevoie en revanche déconvenue
pour trappe bois d'arcy ou encore
montigny le bretonneux autres résultats
les victoires des mureaux et de
versailles à l'extérieur guyancourt
s'est imposé largement 6 0 contre mons
ou et victoire logique de neauphle qui
évolue en régionale face à noisy le club
le sec pardon club de départementale
toujours en football la 6e journée de
nationale 2 et nouvelle défaite pour les
yvelinois
les montois se sont inclinés 2 à 1 à
l'extérieur face à l'en avant guingamp
deux fois ci de son côté a perdu à
domicile face au fc gobelins et restons
à poissy avec un nouveau membre au sein
du staff de l'entraîneur laurent
fournier
habib bèye a rejoint le club yvelinois
l'ancien footballeur professionnel passé
par l'olympique de marseille auxerre ou
le paris saint-germain il occupe aussi
un poste de consultant sur canal+
on poursuit cette page de résultats avec
du handball féminin avec de la nationale
2 montigny le bretonneux s'est imposé
sur le score de 32 à 28 ce samedi 14
septembre une rencontre à domicile au
gymnase pierre de coubertin face au
paris saint germain
et pourtant les alimentent n avait mal
débuté la partie
le récit de la rencontre sur des images
de patrick jacques de dixmude de la joie
du soulagement pour les handballeuses de
montigny le bretonneux pour leur premier
match de la saison elles se sont imposés
32 à 28 face au psg ce samedi 14
septembre au gymnase pierre de coubertin
une rencontre mal débuté par les
inimités début est difficile
dur de rentrer dedans après
c'est vrai que toute l'équipe a était
pas vraiment dedans mais on a réussi
quand même on va dire est resté soudé et
de faire une bonne deuxième mi-temps
quoi le couac il a parlé dans la vie
chère mené sur le score de 14 à 17 à la
mi temps brahim saïdi nouvel entraîneur
des féminines de montigny le bretonneux
donne des consignes pour relancer son
équipe face à la ténacité des
parisiennes les yvelinoises réussissent
à prendre le score
elle ne le lâcheront pas jusqu'à la fin
de la partie en deuxième mi temps on a
essayé de justement corriger ça aux
vestiaires donc on a demandé justement
d'être plus agressives en défense d'être
vus compacts nous travaillons ensemble
sur un bloc et c'est ce qui nous a
réussi donc on a eu aussi l'efficacité
qu'on n'a pas eue au premier mettant nos
objectifs déjà on est en train de
construire un groupe qui est solide on a
essayé d'oeuvre en a eu des départs on a
on a dû recrues il faut que la
mayonnaise prenne donc on joue un match
par match
un nouveau projet de jeu mis en place
par l'entraîneur avec la volonté d'avoir
une continuité dans le travail à
l'entraînement pour la deuxième journée
les inhumant ten se déplace à
aulnay-sous-bois ce dimanche 22
septembre à 16 heures on a calé pierre
chevallier sur notre plateau bonsoir ça
lui nicolas sarrat je dois être et bien
on regarde maroc alors ouais c'est ça
c'est une petite petite escapade
professionnel très très très très
ensoleillé très bien je suppose que vous
avez le sourire parce que au rugby-club
de versailles la tempête a emporté ce
week-end alors avant de parler de la
prière halle 3 on va parler de la
fédérale 2 1 avec une longue page rugby
donc on commence avec la fédérale 2
premiers matchs de la saison réussie
pour le plaisir rugby club une victoire
16 à 7 face à l'équipe du rheu et la
victoire donc qu'on attend que vous
attendez la fédérale 3 donc les
versaillais sont allés l'emporter sur le
terrain des parisiens de massif central
oui parce qu'il faut préciser que c'est
matip centrale mais ce sont des
parisiens le score 43 à 25 une victoire
assez large pour ce premier match pour
votre retour en fédérale 3 c'est assez
inattendu ça faisait trois ans qu'on
avait quitté le niveau fédéral pour
batailler en honneur on savait que ce
serait assez compliqué de
de remonter il nous aura fallu trois ans
après cette saison record de la saison
dernière effectivement et on avait on
avait pas mal d'interrogations savoir en
gros si notre recrutement avait été bien
ciblés si l'entraînement on s'était bien
passée la préparation physique avait été
suivi par les joueurs pendant l'été et
si la reprise le 6 août donc assez tôt
pour un club comme le nôtre porté ses
fruits et donc évidemment de savoir
qu'elle est qu'elle allait notre niveau
est-ce qu'on allait être sur la sur la
lancée de cette saison 2018 2019
ou est ce que on allait d'entrée
ferrailler avec les bonnes équipes des
bonnes équipes de la poule
une poule très parisienne où l'avez vous
l'avez rappelé et effectivement
contrôlés contre les auvergnats de paris
au massif central mais ça s'est très
bien passé avec un très beau match
beaucoup de jeu on avait aussi les
l'application des nouvelles règles
les nouvelles règles de la fédération
française de rugby notamment pour la
protection des joueurs concernant les
plaquages l'objectif la cage ans en
dessous de la ceinture alors c'est ça on
avait beaucoup de beaucoup d'inquiétudes
et d'interrogations savoir si ça n'est
pas trop haché le jeu
ça a été un petit peu le cas c'est à
dire qu'en gros on a on a ça siffle
assez assez souvent plus souvent
qu'avant parce que parce que c'était
assez dur à interpréter arbitré pour les
arbitres mais en tout cas
en tout cas on a on a contourné cette
petite nouveauté par du jeu il va
revenir c'est très prochainement le 20
septembre
est ce que c'est cette préparation vous
l'avez dit cette préparation qui a
commencé le 6 août qui a permis
justement d'être performante dès le
premier match alors oui je pense qu'il
ya trois facteurs le premier c'est qu'on
est dans la continuité par rapport à la
formation c'est à dire que notre notre
objectif étant d'avoir d'avoir un
maximum de juniors formés au club qui
joue en seigneur ça se vérifie une
deuxième année consécutive avec petite
dizaine de juniors maintenant montants
qui sont dans le groupe senior et qui
était dans groupe e dimanche dernier
deuxièmement c'est un c'est
effectivement une préparation ciblée
avec un nouveau staff un nouveau
préparateur 6
physique et qui a fait du des merveilles
pendant l'été en plein coeur de l'été
parce qu effectivement démarré le
redémarrer le 6 août on vous savait pas
si on aurait vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
de monde mais finalement et tous les
versaillais ont répondu présent au fur
et à mesure puis troisième facteur c'est
le recrutement où on avait identifié
certains certains manques et certaines
faiblesses sur certains postes après
notre saison en honneur et puis on a on
a eu la chance d'avoir une bonne presse
grâce aux différents médias régionaux
pendant toute la saison dernière et donc
des types qui sont intéressés par le par
l'opération et par le projet et parle
parce qu'on met en place et l'esprit du
club à versailles et donc on a on a
intégré des très bons nouveau des tout
bons qui ont vite pris leur place dans
l'effectif et on peut presque dire que
la mayo a commencé à prendre du fait de
cette victoire à l'extérieur qui est
quand même une performance pour le
premier match d'une saison
est ce que les objectifs vont être revus
à la hausse on pourrait imaginer
peut-être une montée alors ça c'est
peut-être compliqué il monte en fera
lundi 2 mai au moins jouer le haut de
tableau on va pas évidemment pas
sandales et là je vais faire je vais
faire de la grosse langue de bois mais
mais c'est c'est c'est prendre ces
matches comme ils viennent
effectivement c'est assez inattendu de
démarrer comme ça avec une victoire
probante à l'extérieur avec un bonus
offensif
donc on envoie un message on envoie un
message indirect à la houe direct à la
poule aux équipes de la poule quant à
savoir si les objectifs peuvent être
vues le premier objectif est celui du
maintien
c'est pouvoir inscrire versailles dans
la durée en fédérale 3 ce que ça peut
peut-être changé mais encore encore une
fois il faut il faut attendre
il faut attendre la fin par exemple d'un
premier bloc de trois matchs pour
pouvoir imaginer mieux c'est peut-être
d'aller chercher une place de qualifié
en championnat de france ça c'est
peut-être c'est peut-être envisageable
mais il ya un grand nombre de bonnes
équipes dans cette poule et notamment
qui sont fédérale 3 depuis longtemps et
qui vont nous donner du fil à retordre
le rugby-club de versailles pour a
complete compter cette année sur un
pilier expérimenté son nom guillaume
pommier il veut aider le club à se
maintenir cette saison en fédérale 3
guillaume pommier ses 35 ans 1 m 84 115
kg
c'est la séquence trois questions à
guillaume pommier
[Musique]
pour les potes parce que j'avais des
potes qui sont encore ici d'ailleurs
sont notamment entraîneur pour certains
ici qui m'avait motivé à faire du rugby
n'ont du coup je les ai rejoints et
c'est comme ça que conseiller rugby
moi je voulais finir parce que je pense
que ce sera la dernière année pour moi
de rugby et donc je voulais finir sûr
sûr sûr une autre une bonne note
ma petite carrière de rugbyman après
c'est presque 30 ans de rugby et donc du
coup voilà j'ai voulu relever un dernier
challenge et un dépôt jaksic tiphaine de
charolles m'avait proposé de venir le
rejoindre puisque la règle en tant
qu'entraîneur et donc voilà je les ai
suivis pour ce dernier de challenge
avant de raccrocher les crampons
[Musique]
qui vaut personnel c'est d'essayer de la
tribu matis essai de pommes blessé c'est
de bien préparer physiquement parce que
arriver à stone age on se blesse très
facilement la récup c'est pas la même
donc du coup voilà ccfa maximum de
matches possibles et au programme ce
week-end pour le rugby club de
versailles le premier match de la saison
à domicile au stade de porchefontaine
pour la deuxième journée de fédérale 3
ce sera face à sucy ce dimanche 22
septembre à 15 heures on va passer à la
coupe du monde de rugby pierre chevalier
dans quelques jours le monde de l'ovalie
aura à rendez-vous 1 au japon avec le
début de la coupe du monde du 20
septembre au 2 novembre
pierre chevallier d'abord qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de ce mondial
c'est toujours un événement avait
attendu tous les quatre ont il va
prendre une teinte particulière cette
année parce que le japon comme comme
décor c'est assez inédit dans le monde
du rugby et pour pour accueillir une
coupe du monde
on ne le sait peut-être pas pas beaucoup
mais les japonais sont assez sont assez
fan de rugby depuis quelques années
l'équipe nationale du japon est en train
de progresser grandement au fur et à
mesure à s'aguerrir dans les clubs avec
avec un flux de deux retraités de haut
niveau avec notamment des exoterres
nationaux qui vient de finir leur
carrière au japon et je pense qu'avec le
l'esprit des japonais cette culture de
la compétition
on pourrait presque transport transposer
du sud du sumo pilier au pilier de rugby
vont pas être trop trop trop trop
dépaysé en tout cas nous on va l'être et
on attend vraiment avec impatience cette
7e coupe du monde à l'autre bout du
monde même si ce sont des horaires qui
vont être un petit peu inégal et
inhabituelle ça va changer un petit peu
l'esprit de la troisième mi temps
du coup on prendra près de bière avec
modération bien sûr mais plutôt le café
et les biscottes
c'est une c'est une des nouveautés
imposé par le fait par ce tirage au sort
et de que le japon organise la coupe du
monde ce sont des petites petit déjeuner
match donc effectivement tous les tous
les clubs et tous les aficionados et les
fans de rugby s'organise en conséquence
puisque la plupart des mains jointes
où es tu as entre 9 heures et 11 heures
donc on s'organisera quand ça tombe le
samedi c'est assez facile après en
semaine en semaine y aura peut-être des
rendez vous clients qui vont s'organiser
à droite à gauche à ces heures-là 1 2
questions concernant l'équipe de france
la vitrine du rugby français alors une
question déjà sur est ce que on a nos
chances est ce que les bleues ont leur
chance dans ce mondial et la question en
lien c'est par rapport à l'impact que
peut avoir cette coupe du monde
dans les clubs locaux les clubs divine
aux as que déjà vous avez senti par
rapport à cette coupe du monde
une mobilisation des jeunes de plus en
plus de jeunes dans les écoles de rugby
ou pas alors parce que je pense que ça
sera ça sera plus vrai après la coupe du
monde une fois qu'une fois tous les
matches ont passé et pour peu que
l'équipe de france face à face entre
âgées comme elle a l'habitude de le
faire parce qu'on
parce que depuis le début des coupes du
monde l'équipe de france a toujours
passé les quarts de finale - s'est
qualifié pour les quarts de finale est
passée et avec quelques quelques
justement quelques gros faits d'armes
historiques notamment contre les blacks
ce don ce qu'on peu ce qu'on peut dire
sur l'équipe de france actuelle c'est
qu'effectivement elle n'est pas attendue
elle est outsider et on sait que les
bleus ont toujours aidé n'ont jamais été
meilleur que quand il n'était pas
attendu
on va déjà avoir une première grosse
difficulté c'est de sortir de la poule
dans les deux premiers de la poule ville
centre et voilà contre l'argentine sait
déjà c'est déjà battre des prétendants à
la qualification
il ya l'ogre anglais car il ya près
derrière et toujours se méfier puisque
ne se méfier des tonga notamment parce
que on a déjà perdu contre eux en coupe
du monde donc donc bien se méfier
elle n'est pas attendue on parle pas
beaucoup d'elle malgré tout ça reste ça
reste comme vous l'avez dit la vitrine
du rugby français donc donc mine de rien
on a toujours un esprit supporters même
si on a été déçu sur sur pas mal de
saisons sur pas mal de tournois des six
nations où certains certains matches
amicaux récents on est toujours derrière
notre équipe et on espère bien que
premièrement elle va sortir de poule et
que deuxièmement et puisse faire un coup
parce que c'est une vraiment une équipe
de coupe du monde qui est capable en eau
en autogestion ou avec un staff remaniée
nouveau maintenant même s'il man je
pense qu'ils ont trouvé la mayo tous
ensemble autour de brunel et de galtier
mais je pense qu'ils sont capables de
faire de faire quelque chose de bien ce
qui sort des poules donc sur le nombre
de licenciés on verra à la fin de la
compétition début novembre
et justement on va parler d'un enfant du
club du rugby de versailles il joue
aujourd'hui à massy mais il a surtout
connu ses premières sélections en équipe
de france moins de 18 ans il s'agit de
léobard et quels souvenirs vous garder
de ce joueur au rugby club de leers le
premier souvenir que j'en garde c'est
celui de son père donc j'ai joué avec
arnaud pendant quelques années au
rugby-club de faire ça et puis après on
a vu effectivement le petit léo qui a
ressemble beaucoup à son père et à son
grand père michel donc michel qui a été
président du rugby-club versailles est
qui et qui a qui était propriétaire et
animateur de l'institution versaillaise
le haut parisse toujours avec modération
bien sûr le petit léo il était déjà il
était déjà avec un ballon dans les mains
avec son grand père et son père et puis
moi ce qui met ce qui m'a surtout marqué
au fur et à mesure ces sons comme comme
pour beaucoup de jeunes de cette
génération là c'est son développement
physique naturel avec avec une
propension déjà dépassé son père très
très rapidement maintenant il va nous
manger sur la tête et donc d'aider
d'entrée des attitudes technique et
physique qu'il promettait un très bel
avenir
et c'est totalement justifié de le voir
à ce niveau là maintenant que parce
qu'aujourd'hui donc il joua m'assimiler
au pôle espoir lakanal à aso il a
intégré l'équipe de france moins de 18
ans cet été on va le voir sur ces images
en préparation au centre national du
rugby à marcoussis avec l'ensemble des
joueurs sélectionnés alors là ce sont
des images d'entraînement au pôle pôle
espoir mais on va voir les images
normalement arriver ce au centre
national de marcoussis dont ils ont
préparé pendant le mois de juillet une
tournée en afrique du sud pendant cette
tournée ils ont notamment affronter les
sud-africains l'angleterre et le pays de
galles
l'occasion pour les au bar et d'inscrire
son premier essai on va voir aussi les
images arrivé c'était lors d'un match
contre les sud-africains léobard et qui
joue donc demi d'ouverture vous parliez
de sa taille c'est rare de voir un
ouvreur aussi franck à ma génération
complètement désormais ces deux c'est de
moins en moins en moins rare de voir des
gabarits comme soleure en trois quarts
puisque effectivement
maintenant on a on avait plutôt tendance
à avoir des petits gabarits ou des
gabarit longiligne mais lui il est
costaud il est trapu et grand et une
grande île à une grand avantage rente
avantage c'est qu'il y peut jouer pas
mal de postes derrière là notamment en
tournée en afrique du sud il a couvert
l'ouverture en dise et le centre en 12
il a eu ses sélections justement entre
entre ces deux postes là et ça démontre
déjà déjà de bonnes bonnes attitudes
technique il est habile de ses mains il
ya un coup de pied donc c'est un tout
bon espoir et on est très fiers
évidemment rugby-club versailles de
l'avoir vu avec l' or voilà on est en
train de voir les images justement de
son essai qui m'a inscrit donc en
afrique du sud
une poste du numéro 9 qui prend
l'intervalle il aplatit derrière la
ligne et justement nous l'avons
rencontré léo il revient sur son
aventure dans l'hémisphère sud avec
l'équipe de france moins de 18 ans on
les écoute ça représente une grosse
étape là ça représente beaucoup de jeu
pour l'équipe de france c'était très
intense surtout qu'on a joué deux
équipes 2001
du coup ça nous a nous a montré que
fallait bien continuer à bien travailler
pour arriver au haut niveau
pierre chevallier une réaction par
rapport à ses propos il a la tête sur
les épaules il a il a bon sang ne
saurait mentir déjà dans le
techniquement il a il a tout le tout le
package que la génétique lui a donné par
son grand père et son père et puis la
ilaha illa par l'expérience d'arnaud
sont peu son papa à un certain nombre de
d'éléments qui le drive qui le drive
bien qu'il garde la tête froide il assez
il a fait jusqu'à maintenant des bons
choix déjà celui de celui de choisir
l'école de rugby de durée du rcv de
versailles
mais après d'aller à massy de bien
évoluer de bien évoluer de prendre le
temps prendre le temps de maturer faut
savoir que il a il a failli manquer
cette cette sélection parce qu'il était
blessé il s'est blessé sur un tournoi
juste avant juste avant d'apprendre
qu'il était sélectionné il a réussi à se
remettre sur pied et puis à profiter
pleinement de cette cette fantasy et
fantastique expérience est hélas là
encore une fois s'il prend bien le temps
s'il s'entraîne que la suisse continue à
bien sans trop de s'entraîner à faire
les bons choix je pense que je pense
qu'on va le voir
on espère le voir loin merci pierre
chevalier avec ps est revenu sur notre
plateau du rugby-club de versailles on
met le réveil à 9 heures à 9 heures
samedi prochain même un peu plus tôt
pour le match le premier match de la
coupe du monde france argentine et
dimanche au stade de porchefontaine à 15
heures consensus le premier match de
versailles pour 30 pour la réserve
le premier match voilà le premier match
de la saison pour son retour en fédérale
3 merci bonne soirée et à bientôt
cyclisme c'était la fête du vélo à
montigny-le-bretonneux de vendredi à
dimanche plusieurs randonnées
cyclotouriste et vtt étaient au
programme cet événement pour les âmes
héros les amoureux du vélo était
organisée par le vélo club de montigny
le bretonneux manon varaldo la fête du
vélo s'est déroulé pendant trois jours à
montigny le bretonneux
de vendredi à dimanche elle a rassemblé
cyclotouristes et vététistes
la grosse différence c'est que nous on
lui déroule principalement sur les
chemins en forêt le cyclo lui va rouler
principalement sur la route plusieurs
courses étaient proposés pour cette fête
du vélo le 33e rallye du parc naturel
régional
nagle de la haute vallée de chevreuse et
la 27e rando raid des renards du manet
des parcours allant de 25 à 105 km une
initiative du club de vélo de montigny
le bretonneux
il fête ses 40 ans cette année on a la
chance d'être proche de la vallée de
chevreuse et donc d'avoir un terrain de
jeu agréable et riche également en
histoire puisque puisque tout ceci se
déroule autour des châteaux et de lieux
historiques de la région du sud des
idées ni les parcours se déroule
principalement à travers le parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
les départs des courses se sont
effectuées au gymnase jules ladoumègue
cette participante s'apprête à pédaler
pendant 25 km le but c'est de rouler
dans notre région qui est magnifique
en fait et on découvre notre région
grâce au vélo
après deux mois d'hôpital pour cet
adhérent le vélo et sa convalescence
c'est agréable de faire du vélo tu fais
moi et puis ça me remet en selle un
petit peu parce que je suis un ancien du
club depuis 28 ans dont j'ai eu un petit
souci de santé
et voilà je reprends ça fait une petite
semaine puis aujourd'hui c'est
merveilleux cette fête du vélo de
montigny le bretonneux attiré plus de
2000 participants
[Musique]
avis aux amateurs de la petite balle
jaune le haut niveau s'est installé à
plaisir pour une semaine avec son
tournoi international futur messieurs
une douzaine de nationalités différentes
des joueurs classés entre la les trois
centièmes et cinq centièmes première
place mondiale pour un tableau plein
avec 48 joueurs
ce tournoi qui existe depuis 1993 à
plaisir est le plus gros tournoi
d'ile-de-france après roland garros et
bercy il a vu passer de grands noms tels
que jo wilfried tsonga et michaël llodra
si vous voulez y assister l'entrée est
gratuite deux plaisirs oies sont même
qualifiés dans le tableau final
la grande finale aura lieu dimanche 23
septembre à 15 heures on écoute le
président du club
c'est un tournoi qui permet à tous les
chenilles professionnel à tous les
espoirs
les jeunes espoirs qu'ils soient
français ou étrangers
évidemment de d'avoir des points atp
voir des politesses maintenant et
ensuite d'aller dans des tournois plus
importants comme les challengers ou bien
les grands chelems et pourquoi pas
basket et les féminines du chesnay
versailles sont remontés en nationale 2
cette saison les versaillaise accueil
dunkerque que ce samedi 21 septembre à
20 heures au gymnase du bel air aux
chaînés rocancourt pour leur premier
match de la saison ce week-end elles
l'ont emporté à l'extérieur 62 71
nous sommes allés les rencontrer durant
leur préparation reportage
[Musique]
après une saison de 2018 2019 a réussi
les féminines du chesnay versailles font
leur retour en nationale 2 une nouvelle
étape des nouveaux défis pour les
joueuses emmenées par leur coach vinko
bardy qu on continuer notre travail de
l'année dernière on va se baser sur
notre défense et on va essayer de jouer
avec beaucoup de contre attaques comme
on vient de monter de nationale 3 une
nouvelle équipe avec trois nouvelles
choses
il faut qu'elle s'adapte le maintien
c'est notre objectif
durant l'intersaison trois départs à
noter comblé par l'arrivée de trois
recrues et dites nobles et si l'
international équatorienne arrivée d'une
université canadienne
mathilde marchèrent en provenance de
palaiseau et laurine kerboeuf qui évolue
en nationale une la saison dernière avec
l'équipe de saut mais jerry d'une verte
asteur défense donc c'est vraiment sympa
on prend du plaisir quand au stade c'est
plus intensif en nationale 2 ce que
généralement nationale 3 les personnes
qui jouent sont un peu plus âgés donc un
peu moins et un peu moins d'énergie sur
le terrain mais c'est surtout ça et puis
même la façon de jouer enfin la façon de
réfléchir dans le jeu
nationale de classement la capitaine
arrache dana radenkovic a déjà foulé les
parquets de nationale 2 avec le chesnay
versailles avec une reprise au mois
d'août elle est satisfaite de la
préparation de l'équipe
elles sont arrivées bien préparer déjà
et au fur et à mesure avec les
instruments on a remonté une autre forme
et je pense pour l'instant pour
commencer le championnat on est prêtes
on n'est pas encore à 100% mais et je
pense que les filles aussi et sont près
de genève joue en nationale 2 et 2 de se
maintenir pour commencer après on verra
rendez vous ce samedi 21 septembre pour
cette première à domicile de la saison
c'est à 20 heures au gymnase du bel air
au chesnay rocancourt et avant de se
quitter ces images du colosse une
légende du sport français teddy riner de
ce passage dans les yvelines samedi
dernier le judoka étaient présents pour
une opération commerciale dans une
concession automobile de mantes-la-ville
plusieurs enfants de clubs locaux ont pu
approcher le double médaillé olympique
et champion du monde à dix reprises
teddy riner qui a repris l'entraînement
ce lundi à l'insep après son forfait cet
été aux mondiaux de tokyo
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis et retour du 7-8
sports lundi prochain à 18h30
d'ici là passez une excellente semaine
sportive
[Musique]